bonjour jean marc sylvestre bonjour à
vous merci d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france à
l'heure ce plan de relance est bloqué en
allemagne à karlsruhe
on vient de jouer un sale tour à l'union
européenne en suspendant justement cette
ratification sur lequel on est déjà très
en retard ça représente combien ce plomb
et ça devrait fonctionner quand et sur
quels mécanismes surtout pas écouter
c'est un coup dur parce que c'est un
coup dur pour toute l'union européenne
qui avait besoin d'un plan de relance
coordonnée pour sortir de là deux
actrices du coc vide ça représentait 750
milliards d'euros qui avait été négociée
l'année dernière vous vous en souvenez
pour être payable d'ailleurs dès le
début de cette année 2021 donc on est
déjà en retard pour permettre aux
économies de redémarrer alors ce plan
devait être ratifiée au préalable par
les parlements de tous les états membres
on a pris beaucoup de retard parce qu'il
ya eu des discussions qui ont été un peu
dur notamment avec la hongrie la pologne
les pays bas tout ça s'est arrangé en a
pris également du retard avec un symbole
de pays du sud notamment l'italie est
maintenant à la veille du jour j c'est
l'allemagne qui bloque qui bloque tout
en suspendant cette ratification à la
demande de la cour de karlsruhe vous le
disiez qui a le pouvoir d'intervenir en
allemagne surtout les comptes publics au
service du pont tryba pour ça que la
carte
la cour de karlsruhe par exemple est
déjà intervenu sur l'application des des
plans de maastricht concernant les
budgets alors dans ce cas ben c'est le
groupe souverainiste et libéral qui a
demandé à la cour de tout revoir alors
c'est un coup dur aussi parce que on en
avait tous besoin de cet argent
c'est un coup dur parce que si on ne
remet pas le paquet très vite on va
encore prendre du retard dans le
redressement
surtout par rapport aux états unis qui
ont défini la semaine dernière un plan
massif de relance de joe biden a mis sur
la table 1 milles 1 mille 900 milliards
de dollars pour refaire partir
l'économie américaine et sa fragile
odile d'autant l'union européenne qui
n'a déjà pas fait d'exploit dans la dans
la gestion de ces vaccins ans jean-marc
pourquoi ce blocage quelles sont les
raisons
toi vous savez on retrouve toutes les
raisons qui traduisent la méfiance que
les allemands nourrissent à l'encontre
de l'union européenne ce plan de relance
était pour la première fois fédéraliste
il y là bas ils préparaient une espèce
d'avancé important sur le plan politique
je vous le disais 750 milliards financés
ils étaient financés par des prêts
mutualisés c'était la première fois
c'est très nouveau quand on faisait
appel à ce qu'on appelle des 'eurobonds'
on a beaucoup appelez ça de robots dans
avait éliminé le terme parce qu'il était
tabou politiquement mais c'est l'europe
finalement qui garantissait les prêts en
dépit de la corse madame merkel balle
beaucoup en allemagne se méfiait se
méfier parce que ça revenait à faire
peser sur l'allemagne l'essentiel des
risques d'impayés puisque les allemands
constituent le pays le plus riche de la
communauté européenne à la con
constitutionnel va vérifier que ce type
de prêt est légal alors qu'en réalité
les allemands ne veulent pas payer pour
les autres
ils n'ont pas confiance ils veulent
savoir ce qu'on va faire tous deux cet
argent ils soupçonnent beaucoup de pays
d'ailleurs européens d'utiliser cet
argent à autre chose qu'à raqqa de
l'investissement productif pour sortir
de la crise des allemands quand même un
peu raison de se méfier compte tenu des
dépenses publiques qui ont été faites un
peu partout qu'il ya des pays comme
l'italie l'espagne la grèce la france
bien sûr avec son quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est déjà très endetté et avec des
plans d'investissement qui sont
relativement flou quand même
justement cet argent on doit servir à
quoi exactement
elle devrait servir à la thatcher vous
avez bien vu vous avez une étude qui
vient de souligner de de finir que que
les femmes n'avaient pas beaucoup en
profiter dans la mise à égalité avec les
hommes d'ollé dans les plans de
rémunération et d'entreprises chaque
pays devait soumettre un programme la
france a présenté un programme de
financement avec des grandes mutations
trois points les mutations digital
financer massivement cette accélération
les mutations énergétiques la lutte pour
le climat
et puis enfin il s'agissait de financer
la réindustrialisation c'est à dire la
souveraineté la productivité nationale
avec un accompagnement social alors bref
tout cela est quand même assez floue il
ya des plans sur l'aéronautique sur
l'automobile certes les programmes
pas encore bien défini la france a déjà
dépensé en gros l'année dernière 500
milliards d'euros sur son propre budget
ce c'est de l'argent qui a été emprunté
c'est dans le cadre du du quoi qu'il en
coûte
elle devait encore en dépenses et
pratiquement 130 milliards dans ce plan
de relance dont près plus du tiers
financés dont par l'europe elle devait
dépenser 130 milliards je vous le disais
pour sortir de l'après goût feat
on sait que de toute façon ça ne suffira
pas et à guam l emmanuel macron lors du
sommet exceptionnel la semaine dernière
avait mis un peu les pieds dans le plat
en disant qu'il faudrait au moins plus
du double alors on n'en est pas au
double on en est à statuer sur les 750
milliards qui sont actuellement bloqués
alors qu'est ce qui peut se passer
maintenant écouter entre le fiasco des
vaccins parce que c'est un fiasco et le
retard sur le plan de relance l'union
européenne va avoir besoin d'une
refondation totale
ou alors ces naufrages en naufrage j'y
crois pas trop parce que c'est qu'on
n'est quand même pas deux sur le titanic
mais vous avez une institution qui
fonctionne très bien
la bce l'euro tout le monde s'appuie sur
l'euro parce que tout le monde a besoin
de l'euro y compris les allemands et
c'est ça la force de l'europe finalement
pas ce que l'euro donne des garanties de
stabilité et de crédibilité
tout le monde y croit tout le monde veut
le protéger mais à terme à terme c'est à
dire on dirait des contrats sortie de
cette crise de la pandémie mais l'europe
a évidemment besoin d'une relance
politique alors c'est pas pour demain
c'est pas pour après-demain parce que
après la crise pandémique
on va rentrer dans une crise n est pas
dans une crise politique mais on va
rentrer en période électorale et on sait
très bien que ce n'est pas en période
électorale qu'on va organiser une grande
refondation politique de l'europe
merci beaucoup jean-marc pour toutes ces
précisions jean marc sylvestre stella
est la chronique écho à mercredi
prochain jean marc